where do you think we should come
wherever just enjoy every second of
getting the heck out of Ludlow
[Applause]
the hell is that
[Music]
first place I learned about death was a
pet cemetery
[Music]
a secret place
generation to Generation
Dead things buried in that land
but come back
there's something else
[Applause]
can you hear them
voices
I think something's wrong continue he
needs time to adjust
the people built to pet cemetery to
protect them from evil
it's not Timmy
something's talking through
foreign
[Music]
now stop this
I held him the day he came into this
world and I'm gonna hold him the day he
goes out
believe me when I say
sometimes dead is better
[Music]